the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so today discrete law contracts
which is very linked to lightning
Network so if you didn't get the last
two lectures this might not make that
much sense so hope but I think everyone
here is like up-to-date on these things
so today I'm gonna talk about discrete
log contracts which is a paper I wrote
last summer but it's evolved out of
lightning Network and I'll try to sort
of explain how it you hopefully you'll
see the connections and how you can get
from one to the other
talk about Oracle's talk about
anticipated signatures which has some
fun math things and talk about building
the discrete log contracts themselves
and how that'll work okay so conditional
payments I guess you could call this
smart contracts smart contracts is a
pretty vague term and it's used a lot in
this sort of Bitcoin blockchain etherium
world and usually it's pretty like a lot
of times they use it as a buzz word and
it's like oh like I'll put my land title
in a smart contract and then I can like
buy a house and a lot of times it's used
in ways that's make it seem as though
you don't need a government anymore or a
judicial system anymore to enforce these
contracts and in the case of something
like this tree log contracts that's kind
of true because what bitcoin did and
what made people's pretty impressed was
that hey you don't need a government to
enforce the scarcity of the you know
currency that's being created so that's
kind of cool but it doesn't mean that
you can now use blockchain technology to
not need a government to enforce say
rights to property if you say hey this
is my land and I've got a smart contract
that says my land is you know this is my
land on the blockchain and then like an
army comes and says well we're taking
your farm and you're like no it's on the
blockchain and they don't really care so
so it's hard like another way to think
about it is the only thing the Bitcoin
network can do is move Bitcoin and the
only thing the etherium network can do
is move aetherium to some extent it
doesn't extend
out to like you know autonomous drones
to like shoot you if you trespass or
anything like that yet okay so that so
the simplest and I think most
straightforward and and maybe the most
useful type of smart contract is a
conditional payment where it's basically
I'm gonna pay you based on some external
data so I'm gonna use the example of
Alice and Bob betting on tomorrow's
weather
if it rains Alice gets a coin if it's
sunny Bob gets a coin and we need some
kind of way to get this data right off
weather is not not in Bitcoin and and I
think yeah that is a word that it's
weird like when I'll meet with fancy
rich people like who are getting
companies that come to the Media Lab
know I still use the word bet like to me
everything's a bet right insurance is a
bet like if I buy car insurance I'm
betting Geico or whatever but I'm gonna
crash my car and they're like I bet you
won't and then if I crash my car they're
like ah shoot and then they give me the
money and if I get health insurance I'm
like I bet I'm gonna get cancer and
they're like bet you won't and then if I
get cancer I win and I get a bunch of
money right well so so there's there
they're offset by the fact that you
don't actually want to get cancer and
you don't want to crash your car and so
the fact that you're betting that you
will do it means that in the case that
something bad happens you ask you get a
bunch of money to defer this cost but
fundamentally from the insurance
company's perspective in your
perspective in this insurance contract
it's a bet about whether you're going to
do this or not and like almost all the
financial contracts you can look at as
bets like derivatives and futures and
all those kind of things okay so so keep
it simple for the example there's a very
limited set of outcomes right it's
either rainy or sunny tomorrow and we
don't know that it's gonna what the
weather is gonna be tomorrow yet and
we're gonna bet the clock okay so yeah
we need Oracle's and I would argue that
the Lightning Network script is
essentially a smart contract right the
this key now or this other key later
enlightening however we don't have
external state right there's no need to
query
a third party there's no need to query
the outside world me and all the data
that is used in the channel is generated
by the participants of the channel
themselves right they're making up
random Keys throwing them oh you know
sending them to each other just so that
they can negotiate over the balances in
that channel that said they're probably
exchanging something outside of the
scope of the system right there probably
trading you know I'll give you a little
bit of Bitcoin and for some cookies or
something like that and there's some
delivery of goods or services
that's not a bakery but for the estate
itself it's all internal if we want an
external state we need some way to get
that external state into our system
usually this is called an Oracle okay so
the simplest Oracle would be two of
three multi-sig and there are places
that do this and it's not I don't want
to say it's like a stupid idea it's
actually quite powerful and Bitcoin
enables it in ways that like you
couldn't necessarily do before but
there's problems with it okay so if you
just say two of two multi-sig where
Alice and Bob both put coins into a -
you know into a channel like structure
where they both need to sign and then
they can say okay well at the end of the
you know at the end of tomorrow whether
it's sunny or rainy we distribute the
coins the problem is it gets stuck if
they disagree right also rich players
are an advantage they can say well I I
think I'm right I I'm fine not signing
to get these coins out it's works great
with friends sort of you know
gentlemen's agreement
ladies agreement or shake hands okay
yeah you're right it was sunny but
bitcoin is the currency of enemies so
you want a third party to decide in the
case of conflict there's a lot of
actually interesting sort of game theory
things here where people have tried I've
seen rapport like been to talks where
people are like yeah you don't need an
Oracle you just you know agree on it
without any outside influence and
there's some fun things some fun attacks
where you can basically say okay Alice
it rains you win
but I'm not giving you the money and I
can't get my money back either but
here's what I'll do I'll sign a bunch of
time locks transactions and if you want
a little bit of your money you can take
it right
now if you want more of it you just have
to wait weeks months years and then Bob
can say okay it's up to you right wait
like how much of your money do you want
back you can wait and so you're playing
off the time value of money kind of
thing anyway so I have seen many things
where it's like you don't need an Oracle
just have these two parties agree and
like game theory hand-wave but I have
never been convinced by them like
ultimately if we're in a bet and we
don't trust each other we we need some
arbitrator to decide the outcome of the
bet okay so you have a third party right
you say hey we're gonna bet on you know
this this weather and if there's a
dispute we nominate you know Geoff over
here and he's gonna be the one that
decides whether it actually rained or
was sunny in order to determine who gets
are you gets the money okay so you have
three keys right you've got Alice and
Bob who are in the bet and you've got Oh
Olivia who is the Oracle and if Alice
and Bob Burchill
they both sign and they don't even
contact Olivia right they're like yep it
was rainy okay you get the coins don't
even involve Olivia she doesn't have to
deal with anything but if they fight and
they're saying you know this was totally
not raining it's like right now this is
not rain right this doesn't count like
there's not it's basically sunny so if
they fight about this they can ask
Olivia design either of them can contact
Olivia and say you know hey there my
counter parties either unresponsive or
uncooperative can you sign and then sign
off on the fact that it is in fact
raining I get the coins the problem is
let's say it's sunny and then Alice
tells Olivia hey it's out hey yeah hey
it's Alice say it's raining and I'll
give you a point eight coins right I'm
not supposed to get anything but give me
point two you get point eight win-win
for both of us so the Oracle is can be
influenced and bribed right so the
problem here
you've got interaction between the
Oracle and the participants in the back
two or three multi-sig Oracle's they see
every contract right the the contract
itself is essentially
not a smart contract really anymore
because olivia has to know like the
legalish looking terms of the contract
right Olivia the Oracle has to say okay
in what case do I side with Alice in
what case do I side with Bob
it could be programmatic but it could
also just be a sheet of paper with a
bunch of text on it and Olivia is an
actual person and determines based on
that right so this is this is just sort
of a custodian arbitrator kind of thing
it's not that cool like high-tech
cryptography kind of thing really yeah
and they also decide individually so
they can equivocate so if everyone's
betting on the weather they don't have
to sign that it's sunny universally they
can sign too sunny on this side and
rainy on that side there's nothing you
can do about that so I think what led me
to think about these it'd be better if
the Oracle couldn't equivocate right
they can't determine you know they can't
say two different things and it's even
better if they never see the contract
but how do we do that okay so any
questions about the general setup of
what we're trying to accomplish here
that's and then you can have Moulton you
know lots of different types of bets but
anyway this is the essential problem how
do we do this and like in aetherium most
of the time everything's on chain right
the data sources are published on the
etherion blockchain so you sort of have
similar problems there's ideas of okay
let's have a bunch of Oracle's and then
you sort of take the average of all the
ore there's there's different ways but
this thing is okay make the Oracles
never see the contracts but how okay and
then how is gonna be kind of complicated
so remember these from last time
right these sign with this key and you
have to wait sign with these two keys
and you get it immediately this kind of
you know same same exact script is like
so that will be used okay and then a I
talked about this I'm a third class
about signatures but we're gonna go more
in depth in Schnoor signatures here
okay so in Bitcoin we've got this CCDs
elliptic curve in Bitcoin UCC it is DC e
CDF
elliptic curve digital digital signature
algorithm which is different than what
I'm gonna explain but this aspect is the
same right the public keys are private
keys times the generator point so we we
can do this without actually using the
Bitcoin signature algorithm we can use
our own external signature algorithm and
then use the keys generated by that in
Bitcoin itself okay so a and B lowercase
scalar big a big B uppercase their
points on the curve so what operations
can we do I think this is review but
this was like months ago regular numbers
you can do whatever you want there
regular numbers it's easy add subtract
multiply divide it's literally in the
software just like big in dot add and
the big in addition and multiple there
just you're just adding numbers so you
do whatever you want with these points
points are group they do not have two
operations defined they only have one
operation to find and we call that
addition it's sort of you know like you
could call it something else sometimes
they use a different symbol than plus
but additions sort of what we call it
and it works the way you'd think
addition would work right you add these
two things if you add a and B and then
subtract B you get back to a things like
that okay so you can add them subtract
them you can't multiply or divide right
these are not defined okay and you can
mix these things so you cannot add a
point and a scaler that's also undefined
so if you have like a point here and you
want to add five it doesn't make sense
however you can multiply a point by a
scalar and you can divide a point uh
yeah you can divide that and the way you
do that is you just in the actual
elliptic curve you you two double a
point you take the tangent so instead of
like drawing a line between two points
you say well I'm drawing a line between
this single point which basically means
the tangent as you sort of like think of
like limit as the side the spacing
between those two points goes to zero
and then if you can double a point if
you can add a plus a then you can
multiply by any arbitrary number by
saying okay I'll take two a to be a
tangent I'll take for a to be the
tension to that I'll take a day that'll
be the tangent of that and then you can
add up like you can do binary
decomposition and computers are real
good at that and say okay I'm gonna I
need five a so I'm gonna take a plus for
a right yeah so you can divide devise a
little little annoying but you can do
that okay so you can you've got all
these operations we can do you can do
whatever you want with the scalars you
can add points subtract points multiply
its points by scalars with this alone
you can do and then also well you have
to throw hash functions in there for the
stuff we're gonna do but you guys know
all about hash functions so with this
and hash functions you can do like
ridiculous amounts of stuff it's really
kind of impressive also you say yeah
part of the signature system is you pick
some random point Chi sometimes in other
systems you have G and H two other
points but the idea is everyone just
dude you know agrees we've got some
point G and everyone agrees on it okay a
nice property you can add keys you can
you know the addition sort of works
addition in the scalar world works in
the point world as well right so if you
have a times G Plus B times G and that's
the point that's equal to a plus B times
G also going to be a point so that is
what we're gonna use and you can use
this to share keys right I think I
explained this last time if you know
little a but you don't know little B you
can't sign but if you learn both you can
sign for this you know come this some
pumpkin so this is a way to like share
keys okay
[Music]
okay that's sort of at work anyway snore
signatures which are going to go into
Bitcoin probably not even this year
maybe next year and there's a lot of
cool things you can do with them I think
I'm talking about that next week and
like that's aggregation right but the
basic idea of a snore signature you've
got a public key that you've already
told everyone right so before anything
happens you pick a random private key
little a multiply it by G and then
compute big a and tell the that to the
world either by sin you know having that
is an output address in your Bitcoin
script or publishing it on a website you
know somehow you propagate hey this is
my public key this is me okay and then
when you sign you come up with another
private heat pretty much the exact same
as little a it's gonna be called little
K and then you compute R which is K
times the generator point so this R is
pretty much the same idea as you know
it's another public key but this will
only be used once and then to sign you
compute s which is K that thing you just
made up - the hash of the message to
sign concatenated with R times your
private key okay and then the signature
R is R and s and then for someone to
verify this they know em right the
message you're trying to sign they know
your public key big a they know R and s
your signature and they try to what they
do is they just multiply both sides of
this equation by G right so you can you
can do that same as regular math
multiply both sides by the same thing so
they can't verify this because they
don't know a little a they don't know K
but if you multiply it by G well then
you get s times G equals K times G minus
this hash times a times G well that is
just your public key right
this is R and this you also know because
they gave us so do you know G yeah this
you know s times G so that's how you
verify and it's like there's all sorts
of proofs about why you can't Forge
these and stuff like that but it sort of
makes sense right if you're trying to
forge a signature and you say hey I'm
going to solve for s right well I can't
I can't solve for s directly because I
don't know little a I don't ok the the
problem is I want to okay I want to
solve for some one of these things I've
basically got an equation where I've got
R minus the hash of our and I can't tear
those apart right like I need like how
do I solve for R but there's like the
hash of our and are on the same side of
the equation I could try to move this so
that like okay R equals the hash of our
like wait how am I going to do that
right so any time you try to solve
you're gonna have an R and a hash of are
in the same equation and like that seems
impossible right okay so this is this
issue or signatures it works great it's
got nice lots of nice properties
actually all of this could work in ECDSA
it's just that ECDSA is like really ugly
and complicated but anyway so what
discreet law contracts uses is a fixed R
signature it's the exact same equation
but you sort of move where R is
considered so before you'd say the
public key is a and now my signature is
r and death now we're just gonna say
okay make the public key a and are two
points and make the signature just s so
same equation everything is the same
it's just that you generate K at the
same time you're generating a and
publish both a and R as your public key
right no no problem okay the problem is
you can only sign once that's why you
don't usually do this it's there's no
size difference right it's like okay
well your public key gets twice as big
and your signature gets half as big no
no net gain but you can only sign once
and why yeah I'm actually it looks kind
of scary but it's actually not too bad
so the idea is I sign I have an A and an
R and those don't change right so I have
a little lane okay those don't change
but I'm signing two different messages
so the idea is I have signature 1s 1
which is K minus
the hash of message one could get me to
our times my pregnancy signature - is K
- the house of muscies - in our times I
private key so I published both of these
signatures and then someone says oh I'm
going to subtract these two signatures
from each other right so s1 minus s2
well that would be you know this top
thing - this thing which is K - the hash
of message 1 times a minus K plus the
Hass admissions 2 times a the KS cancel
out that's the important part here so
K's are gone
cool now I've got this s1 minus s2 which
I can compute right s is just a scalar
s1 minus s2 type it's like a you know a
millionth of a second in my computer to
do now I've got this you know this thing
I know s1 minus s2 equals the hash of
message to R times little egg - the hash
of message 1 all right little a I don't
know little it right so I can't I can't
figure out this but I know I know what's
on this side of the equation right I
know this sort of subtracted s what can
I do here
well I can factor out a right because a
is multiplied on both sides of this so
now I can factor you know put a little
parentheses okay this hash is message to
our - the hash of mesh is 1 R times the
private key here and now we can divide
and well this is the whole equation
right I divide out I divide by a little
light here and this thing I know divided
by a thing I don't know equals the thing
I know right so I can move things around
and say ok well then a is this thing I
know right this the difference between
the two signatures divided by the
difference between these two hashes and
those two hashes also I know right I
know what the messages are I know what
the R value is it works so the big thing
here is if you have the same K value and
the same a value you can find their
private key so the normally this is okay
because K is different right so you'd
have K sub 1 K sub 2 here and then if
you build this equation you've got these
Ches which do not cancel out and because
you don't know what they are
and you you don't get anywhere with this
okay but so if you do use the same K
value you will lose your private key fun
fact I first learned about this in like
2011 from the PlayStation 3 code signing
thing and yeah that was gone I think
because I started to get in the Bitcoin
and also it was like Oh PlayStation 3
got hacked cool so Sony had a cave that
like they probably read up on how to do
this and they say ok K needs to be
random so they just made a random number
and hard-coded it as the K that they
used I don't think they realized that
has to be random and different each time
so it was just a single random K yeah
there's other there's other cases of
this being a problem in Bitcoin
blockchain dot info I believe a couple
years ago had something where K was
random but it was like only four bytes
of randomness or something and so you'd
end up getting some occasional case that
were the same and then you could compute
people's private keys there's a couple
other things like that where if you know
so so actually in practice now you don't
make K randomly in most in in Bitcoin
core and most of the Bitcoin libraries
you make K basically the hash of your
private key and the message so that
changes for each message and it's also
got like secret information so no one
can figure it out that that's called RFC
six nine seven nine and it is safer
because you don't keep needing new
randomness each time yes hysteresis
I mean will people can't it like people
have made it in very recent history I
wouldn't be surprised if people continue
to make this mistake you know couple to
three years ago blockchain info had this
where the case were the same it's it's
not immediately uh you know you have to
sort of look for it but yeah people
still make all sorts of mistakes like
this there's there's elliptic curves are
actually less I think of a minefield
than like RSA RSA has all sorts of like
I had no idea that would break the
security the system but it does like you
know an RSA you've got P and Q 2 big
prime numbers you multiply them to get
your modulus and but if P minus 1 or n
minus 1 is smooth which means has many
small factors then you can break it and
find their private key like I didn't
know that until last year in a class I
was like really
oh wow so there's all sorts of bad
things that can happen in elliptic
curves it's kind of nice in that you're
your random numbers can really just be
random numbers so it's not - not as bad
but you do have to watch out for some of
these things ok so what's this new
system right if you're pub key is a n R
and a message M right you cannot compute
s so I know they're public key right I
know
R I know they're like I know this whole
thing
I can't compute s right because s is in
terms of K and little a I can compute s
times G though because that's times G is
in terms of R and big a which I know
right so you can't can be a little less
but you can compute s times G so s times
G is computable for any given message so
if someone publishes this new type of
pump key a and are together I can say ok
well what will it look like if you sign
the message sunny right if you just take
the word sunny stick it in here
concatenated with the R value already
told me hash that multiplied by your pub
key and then subtract that from your R
value I'll get a point on the curve and
I can compute that and I can commute
that from for any M I care to
throw into this equation so this is kind
of neat right I can compute a point on a
curve for any message that you have not
yet signed and then the signature itself
would be s this sort of is looking like
a key pair right so this is an unknown
scalar right I don't know what s is I
but I can compute s times G this is a
public key private key right this is the
exact same set up so now we can use this
for a third-party Oracle to sign
messages and then when they sign the
message they're revealing a private key
to a public key you've already computed
so when I was making this I definitely
didn't start with from our signatures
and do this I had my own crazy scheme
which had like all these different
equations and like R was multiplied by
this other hash and there was all these
things and then I was talking to people
and eventually was like wait you don't
need all this this this is just a snore
signature where I've already known as R
so okay this is much nicer I don't have
to write this whole crazy proof and okay
so we can use this so olivia's and we
can use Olivia's signature s as a
private key in our transactions and we
use s times G as a public key and then
we can also do the fun stuff where we
mix with Alice and Bob's public keys
right so I can say that Alice's pump key
plus s times G is the public key for
this contract and Alice's private key
plus s is the per is gonna be the
private key for this contract so I can
say we what we can do is we can say okay
I'm gonna compute an address where it's
your pump key plus the signature of this
Oracle signing the word sunny times G
and that's the pub key for Alice's sunny
pub key right Alice can only spend this
if the Oracle signs the word sunny and
she has her private key if the Oracle
signs the word rainy Alice doesn't know
how to you know doesn't know learn the
private key any questions about that
part make sense okay so this is kind of
cool
so what you can do so quick recap
lightning you use the you use the
mechanism where you're adding these keys
to revoke old states right you say okay
you
if I give you this key you can outspend
it immediately if I give you this key
you can now spend it immediately so we
enforce that with the most recent one is
like the okay one because if I broadcast
one of these old ones you can
immediately get it in this great log I
switch it around a bit I say you know it
looks like a channel we both put money
into here and then we build three
different transactions all at the same
time before we even you know do anything
before we actually fund this we build
these descent in transactions and the
idea is that the public keys in here
this is Bob's public key but it's also
got the sum you know the sum of Bob's
public key plus the Oracles signature of
the word son
so if Bob broadcasts it the own and the
only way he can immediately take his
funds is if the Oracle have signed the
word Sonny and he knows that s value if
he broadcasts it and then waits
right if he broadcasts it but it's not
actually Sonny then Alice can take the
money after a little while right after a
day you use the same time up procedure
where okay if I broadcast this and I
know the key I immediately sweep it if I
broadcast it and I don't know the key my
counterparty can take everything after a
day so ya all create states are created
the start the validity is a determined
by a non-interactive oracle signature so
the Oracle signs cloudy which is yeah
and now either party can broadcast the
cloudy transaction and then take their
money immediately if anyone tries to you
know if anyone tries to broadcast so for
example if Alice tries to broadcast
rainy at this point the Oracle has
signed the word cloudy they're not going
to sign the word rainy if they do sign
the word rainy they reveal their private
key so if Alice broadcast this her money
stuck she doesn't actually have this key
and then Bob just waits and then takes
all of Alice's money so but you you know
from the network's perspective you can
broadcast any of these transactions but
you don't want to because you don't know
the key it's not your it's not your
funds
okay so yeah in the case where it's
cloudy
how signs
those are transaction signature yeah
because you know that Bob his waist is
Alice's money yeah Alice it's sending to
Alice's public key plus the Oracle
signature public key and Alice can't
sign with that right she does she knows
her private key but she doesn't know the
Oracle rainy private key so she can't
sign with this to take the money so the
money's just stuck here but it's got
that timeout period right it's yes wait
today have it here yeah it's the same
script right it's enlightening its Pub
our or pub T and time right there's a
revocable one and a timeout one yeah so
enlightening it's it's the opposite of
lightning right enlightening correct is
to use the time up all right so I'm
lightning
enlightening I've broadcast this I have
to wait right it's Alice's key that then
takes a day and then I can sweep it
that's the correct thing that happens if
I broadcast this Bob can immediately
take it because I've already given him
the the private key it's the opposite in
discrete law contracts where if I
broadcast the wrong thing it's just
stuck forever I'm never gonna be able to
get it and then my counterparty can get
it after a day if I broadcast the right
thing my counterparty can still get it
after a day right so if Alice broadcast
this alice has to immediately you know
spend this because this Alice five
bitcoins is also Bob's after a day so
she needs to say okay I'm gonna
broadcast this and then immediately
sweep the funds to my own regular
address so what's nice is that's like a
better timing model anyway so in cases
of fraud the recoverable key can be used
after Katie revealed so that's in
lighting right and lightning broadcast
the most recent there is no pub are
right no one can sign this because you
haven't revealed it and then the timing
happens in set so you broadcast your
most recent state you wait a little
while and you don't you don't
have any rush you you know you've never
given pub are away so you can just leave
it and then time elapses
so maybe the timeout is one day you
don't have to spend it after that one
day you can leave it for a week or a
month and then later spend it because
you're really sure your counterparty is
never gonna get this private key so
that's the way lightning works in
discrete log contracts however the time
out one is the incorrect one when you
publish the wrong transaction right huh
Bar is the Oracle signature plus your
you know the Oracles signature plus your
own private key and pub tea is just the
other person gets it after a while so
you should be able to you know you if
you publish the right transaction you
can immediately spend it if you publish
the wrong transaction you'll never be
able to spend it in your counterparty
will next you know tomorrow or next week
so it's kind of a nicer model I think
because enlightening you have to be
watching your channels in discrete log
contract nothing bad can happen if you
go offline so that's really nice
right enlightening you have to watch for
fraud old states could be broadcast and
you got to grab it in DLC sweep it as
soon as you want it's easier you have
the software do both at the same time
there's no surprises so for example in
lightning this is the current state
right Alice has nine coins
Bob can at any time broadcast this
transaction and Alice must respond and
say no that's wrong I'm taking all these
nine coins and your software does that
automatically sure but you have to be
online and you have to you know be
watching the blockchain so surprises can
happen and you know there's software
working on called like watchtowers to
like anonymously outsource watching this
to other people and things like that but
but it's a downside right you you fraud
could occur if you're offline in
discrete log contracts fraud cannot
occur hey I don't want to say that
there's all sorts of things New York who
can do this bad oh but the the idea of I
go offline right I'm Alice I entered in
this contract about the weather on next
week but then I forget about it and I
just don't even sign into my computer
for a month there's no risk that the
wrong thing will happen you know
assuming the Oracle is signing correctly
Bob can't do anything bad right if this
is now endorsed by the Oracle as being
the correct transaction if Bob
broadcasts this or this he can never
take those coins right it's just
indefinitely
stuck here Alice gets her coins with no
restrictions and Bob's coins are just
stuck there forever right he'll never
learn the the key to sign with this and
so Alice can come back in a week come
back in a month and say oh cool Bob
broadcasts the wrong thing you know I
can take these coins at my leisure if
Bob casts broadcasts the right thing and
then immediately takes his coins Alice's
coins are still there everything's fine
so this is I think a nicer timing model
and that you don't have to be online
quickly also it's nicer in that in
lightning if you're being honest
and you'd broadcast the correct
transaction you have to wait that's
anointing right the time out could be a
day or a week or something and maybe
your counterparty you know if your
counterparty is online and cooperative
you don't have to use this transaction
you can just say hey look I want to
close out I've got nine you've got one
let's just build a transaction sending
nine to me and one to you with no no
weird scripts or anything and then Bob
can say okay sure
closing the channel here we go and we
just closed it but if Bob's offline
which happens Alice says shoot I have to
close this channel I want my nine coins
I broadcast this closing the channel and
they have to wait a few days and that's
annoying right that's not great whereas
in discrete log contracts if you're
doing on it let's say I'm I'm Alice Bob
seems to be offline I can't contact him
I say okay Bob you're not there fine
well the it was cloudy I broadcast this
I immediately take my five coins don't
have to wait at all
and the software does both of those at
the same time so this is a nicer timing
model than lightning
yeah no surprises and no waiting the
only time you have to wait is if the
other party you know
Alice would have to wait and you know if
Bob broadcasts let's say Bob brought
broadcasts this Alice gets one point
immediately and nine coins after a few
days so Alice is like well I have to
wait a little but hey I get all the
money even though I was only supposed to
get half great there are some attacks
where for example let's say this was
like zero or like point zero zero one
like basically nothing and the actual
thing that happened was it was raining
and Bob's like shoot I got nothing right
fine I'm just gonna sign this you know I
started I'm just gonna broadcast this
where I get all the money I don't
actually get all the money right alice
is gonna take this after a day but
basically I lost everything anyways so
fine you know like I so that is an
attack where if there's almost no money
on one side Bob can be a jerk and say
well I'm gonna broadcast the invalid
transaction just to prevent my
counterparty from getting her money
immediately she gets it all but maybe
all is pretty close to what she would
have gotten anyway so bob has no real
loss and alice has no real gain there
and then Alice has to waste them some
time waiting so that's an attack the the
easiest way to sort of mitigate that is
to have this kind of construction where
it's like well Bob still got one even
when Bob loses he still gets one coin
back right there's there's extra
collateral in the contract and then he
doesn't want to broadcast their own
thing to to be a jerk
the wrong
the correct
you are a subtraction
if look from the network's perspective
right so if I'm a minor
looking at the Bitcoin network I have no
idea what these things mean right it
just says I'll you know key one coin
other key nine points different you know
I just see two different transactions
spending the same output so if you see
them if you see Bob broadcast this
transaction you actually do not want to
broadcast this probably because you'd
rather have all the money instead of
half even if it takes you some time but
if you if you have you know you're
saying okay I'm Alice I broadcast this
and then Bob broadcast this right after
you're like oh shoot that's a much
better transaction I would I you know
but you don't know which is gonna get in
because the miners have no idea what's
going on so if you see that Bob is being
you know the actuals the actual outcome
was it was rainy Bob sees this and has
so very little money at stake so bob
says fine you know what screw it I'm
gonna broadcast this just so Alice you
know yes sir
you know 0.001 right away but has to
wait a long time for the 9.99
then Alice could say I'm broadcasting
this and then immediately try to spend
it with a high fee you could do that
[Music]
you could yeah you could hope that your
yeah there's so there's no there's no no
rush right
the Oracle signs it was cloudy you've
both got those private keys you can just
wait you know there's no need to
immediately broadcast in him once you
broadcast this you do need to
immediately spend the part that that's
going to you because that also has the
clause that it could go to the other guy
in a week or a day so but yeah and you
can just leave it here you just leave it
don't progress anything and you're like
well maybe he'll screw up and broadcast
the wrong thing and then I'll get all
the money probably not gonna happen but
there's all sorts of things the Oracle
can do that's bad so if the Oracle never
signs none of these will ever be valid
right so you should what the contract
should have is a timeout where if you
know so if we're betting on the price
we're so we're betting on the weather
tomorrow we can say okay well by Monday
if the Oracle hasn't signed anything
we've got a time lock transaction that
just gives us both back five points all
right you know it's a wash trade but
yeah that that that can happen yeah so
hopefully the Oracle doesn't do it okay
but but that's like it's not the end of
the world it's like okay the Oracles not
there so we don't know how to execute
this trade you know this bet so we just
get our money back it didn't work and we
wasted time
oh okay so some scalability fun stuff
you can do discrete log contracts within
a channel so let's say you've got a
lightning channel and if you want to
cooperate if both parties cooperate no
transactions get broadcast the
blockchain at all this is kind of cool
okay so you've got these nested
contracts so this is a lightning channel
right and it's you know Alice has ten
points Bob has 20 points and they've
been making you know lots of different
transactions this is a say the you know
30th 35th state of the transaction
there's all sorts of transactions before
this but they've all been revoked by
sharing
private keys and then you say okay well
Alice has ten points Bob has 20 coins
let's build a contract so we both
decrement our balances by five and then
we create a third output so this is a
it's sort of like having an HDL see
where you've got you know a this sorry
these arrows don't really line up the
right way but um you've got one
transaction with three outputs Alice
gets five coins Bob gets 15 coins and a
new two of two multi-sig gets ten points
from that you build two different colors
or something yeah these are two
different transactions this is all one
transactions all right so from there you
say okay we're gonna build a discrete
log contract that's an output in the
channel and we don't you know if we want
to we can broadcast the whole thing any
of us at any time can say ok I'm
broadcasting this current state of the
channel which is Alice five Bob fifteen
Alice and Bob ten and then I have these
transactions as well and I can broadcast
either of those so if your counterparty
becomes unresponsive you close the
channel and close the contract but if
the counterparty is cooperative then the
Oracle signs okay it was rainy this now
becomes valid both parties agree yeah
you know Alice one nine coins Bob can be
a jerk and just be unresponsive and then
alice is like all right fine
close the channel spend you know
broadcast this transaction broadcast
this transaction take the nine coins
Alice has to do nine Tran
Alice has to do three transactions in a
road to do that but if there's not going
you know that's that's totally doable
right quote you know this to close this
to finalize the contract and then this
to sweep the money to herself before Bob
tries to get it but if Bob's cooperative
and says okay yeah you won this bet and
also we keep doing these contracts we
keep betting with each other this is the
only valid one the other one I'm not
gonna broadcast I'll never get the money
and then we say well Alice got nine
got +9 Bob got +1 we just make a new
state of the channel right so this was
the old state 5 15 10 we went up level
and now the new state is Alice gets 14
Bob gets 16 and then we revoke the old
state so the contract was built you know
the all the different terms of the
contract were built one of them became
known to be valid and then they
basically deleted the whole thing and
they never touched the block right they
saw this was all descendant transactions
within a lightning channel and now we've
got our new balances so we can keep
doing this we can have like five of
these at the same time and then keep
sequentially making all these contracts
what's nice about this is no one ever
sees anything right Alice and Bob know
that they were betting on the weather
nobody else can see that they were
making a bet at all right there's no
transaction that goes onto the watching
in the worst case scenario a transaction
does go onto the blockchain and if you
see this get broadcast the thing is it's
still not clear that it was a contract
you you it could be a channel within a
channel and there's reasons to do that
you could say okay this is our this is
our cold channel that we keep all the
keys offline and this is our hot channel
that we keep transacting very quickly we
can do something things like that so
there's there's reasons to do this
but so the scripts themselves if you
broadcast the transaction look exactly
the same as lightning it's just key a
and time or key B so this is kind of
cool I think okay other other cool
things you can do you can split the
r-value into an exponent and mantissa so
it's hard to explain okay so let's say I
did the example with like sunny and
rainy right but in practice I think
people are going to use this for like
futures contracts where there's like a
bunch of different prices so you could
say okay the price will put the price on
this axis price is $1 $2 $3 for
five dollars for example and then you
know Alice gets money here Bob gets
money here and it can be like that or
something where at one dollar Alice gets
all the money at two dollars
Alice gets most of it three dollars Bob
gets most of it so they're half-and-half
things like that um what might happen is
that there's like knock in and knock out
where if the price is six or seven or
something really high well all the money
goes to Bob that's just how it is and
like you not even sure the order order
of magnitude so it might actually go you
know one and then ten like there might
there might be like orders of magnitude
where okay the current price of
something we're betting on is twenty
dollars right so we actually only care
about the range from $10 to $30 we only
care about and they're like $20 its
Alice and Bob get 50 50
we might not care about what happens if
it's point O you know one cent or what
happens if it goes to $5,000 we don't
care or we care you know but but the
thing is if he goes to $30 or $5,000 the
same outcome happens so we can do is we
can say okay instead of just using one R
value where the the Oracle signs the
price and we have to compute messages
for all the different prices and compute
s times G for all the different prices
they can say okay well we've got our
exponent and our mantissa and mantissa
is a weird word for the thing that's
behind the decimal point
so then I can so exponent you can just
say okay well it's either 10 to the 1 or
10 to the 2 or 10 to the 3 or 10 to the
4 and I'm gonna have an R value for that
and I'm gonna produce an s times G for
that and then the mantissa could be you
know like 1 2 3 4 to 9 something looks
simple like that so in some cases so for
example in the case of
10 to the to 10 to the 3 10 to the 4 we
don't care about the mantissa right if
the exponent is 10 to the 2 3 or 4 or
then Bob gets all the money right away
and if the exponent is 10 to the zero
then Alice gets all the money we don't
have to involve the mantissa at all but
if the exponent is 10 to the 1 then we
actually care and we can just add the
point so we say okay s G equals our 10
to the 1 minus the hash times a and then
this is s G exponent and then s G
mantissa is our you know 3 minus the
hash times a and then we can just add
these two points so we say s G exponent
plus s G mantissa equals the contract as
G contract and that's what we put in our
that's what we put in our contract for
the keys that way we need the Oracle to
sign that the exponent is 10 to the 1
and the number you know the base is 3
okay it was $30 so that way it's it's a
little extra data for the Oracle to sign
but pretty pretty small right next to 32
bytes and then we can potentially save
on a lot of these extra transactions out
in areas that all end up being the same
result to us any questions about that
does that sort of make sense it's an
optimization right you don't have to do
it but it can lead to a lot less data
yeah
[Music]
yeah well it's the ideas the actual
number is going to be our mantissa times
our X you know or 10 to the rxp right so
the actual so if the number was 20 you
say ok 10 to the 1 our X 1 is 10 to the
1
our mantises do if the act of the number
was 5000 you say ok 10 to the 3 5 and
then you just release both of these and
they're they're independent so that the
2 users can use them independently and
the the most likely case is we don't
care about the mantissa we only care
about the exponent so we are we're only
some of our bets only deal with the
magnitude of the price you could also do
that's where you're only dealing with
the mantissa but that seems kind of
silly where it's like I don't care if
it's two dollars or 20 dollars or $200
but anyway if the first digit of the
price starts with 2 you know is 2 I went
you could do that but probably not as
useful but but yeah if and then in the
extreme case the extreme version of this
would be to have bind you know decompose
the number being signed into binary and
then sign every bit and then there's
only two signatures possible for every
bit and then the users can sort of
combine these things in any way they
want more signature data but gives the
users a lot of flexibility okay multi
Oracle another thing you can do so the
problem is these how trustworthy is are
these Oracle's the Oracles can cheat
right they can just easily sign that
it's rainy when it's sunny there that's
publicly knowable and if they have a
reputation that's you know hopefully
hurts them but you are trusting the
Oracle to sign the right thing so maybe
they want to use two Oracle's so that's
totally doable right you have the S the
Oracle a Oracle and the B Oracle and you
just add the two points that you come up
with and then when they both release
their s values you add those two s
points and you'll get the private key
totally easy for n of em there's no
sizing
right you just you can pick 10 Oracle's
add up all those things no one can tell
and your transactions are still really
small for n of M it or usually it's
called M event huh well anyway there's a
sized blow up because you're gonna say
okay well I want two of three and I have
to make new transactions for all these
different combinations and so you end up
having a lot of transactions for small
things like sunny or rainy it's totally
doable for things like where you're
already hitting up against limits where
oh we have to sign thousands of
transactions for all the possible
different prices then this can get very
costly another downside to this is if
they sign different things you get stuck
right so if we say okay we're gonna use
Thomson Reuters Oracle and Bloomberg
Oracle and we're gonna you know use
their price of oil and then one of them
signs
oh it's fifty dollars and three cents
and the other signs that it's fifty
dollars and five cents shoot we can't
you know we just used the same value for
all these SG points to build all the yes
you know the combined points now we
don't have a match so we cannot build
the the point the private key that we're
looking for so this contract either
reverts so that's another reason why you
might want to decompose it this way you
could have a construction where you say
okay we're using Bloomberg and Thomson
Reuters
but for Thomson Reuters we're only using
the exponent and for Bloomberg we're
using both so the idea is if there's a
case where the exponent is different
between Bloomberg and Thomson Reuters
our contract fails but if the case is
there their exponent is the same then we
just go with the actual you know precise
price from Bloomberg so in case Thomson
Reuters gets hacked and they say oh the
price of oil is you know 50 million
dollars a barrel and that could cause
contracts to go the wrong way then
that's sort of a safety catch on there
so there's all sorts of things you can
do like that I don't know how this will
actually work out will there be lots of
different Oracle's my guess is no you
kind of want them to be reputable and
you can't really make money doing it and
it's really scalable and cheap to be an
Oracle because like all you're doing is
sign
things so it feels like the kind of
thing that once you have a you know once
you get some momentum you're just gonna
be this monopoly and everyone's gonna
use the same Oracle but who knows yeah
Oracle problem so so yeah we're cooks
can lie they can also they can they can
equivocate right they can sign two
different things but then they reveal
their private key so you might want them
to post coins on the blockchain
with their a you know that's that's got
their their regular public key a so that
if they ever do sign to the same message
then they lose their money and everyone
can try to grab it yeah what are the
other things oh I was going to talk
about innovation time yeah so so another
thing that people like to do with these
types of contracts is enter into
contracts and then sort of sell their
position in the contract so for example
if we were in a contract about the
weather and I look outside I'm like oh
it's definitely gonna be rainy like so
the the Oracle is gonna sign about the
weather as of noon like it's 11 o'clock
it's gonna be rainy I want to sort of
lock in my profit and it's not exactly
sure yet
so there may still be some value to the
sunny position but it's looking pretty
grim for the sunny position I might just
contact my counterparty and say hey
let's close early right I don't need the
entire profit but like give me 90
percent of it because it's you know
pretty rainy and they might agree to do
that but a better way to do it would be
to say I'm going to let someone else
take my position so for example if you
have so if you've got like Alice and Bob
are in a contract and then there's like
Alice gets nine Bob gets one for Sun and
then Alice gets one Bob gets nine for
rain and then they say okay let's just
do it early Bob Bob might not be
cooperative but Bob
Alice wants to say let's just get out of
it right now at some at one of them you
know a little bit less than this bob
says no I want to keep holding it
through what Alice wants to do is say
look I'm gonna replace myself with Carol
Alice finds some other person Carol -
now have a Carol Bob transaction where
it's the same exact contract so be
carole91 and Carol one Bob nine for Sun
and rain so what's nice about this is
from Bob's perspective nothing changes
except the counterparties public key
which Bob doesn't care about right so
Alice can say hey Bob let's switch this
transaction you have the same exact
payout based on the same exact
signatures from the Oracle so it's no
change to you it's just that my public
key is gonna change because it's
actually gonna be someone else and then
Bob that way Bob software can
automatically do it this is still
interactive in that Bob's keys have to
sign right Bob needs to make a new
signature spending from here to go into
this new - of - output so that's new so
their computer has to be on and they
have to sign but you can make the
computer software do it automatically
because there's no user interaction
needed in that it's like hey your
position didn't change and then probably
put in something where like Alice pays
Bob a little extra right Alice gives Bob
of dollar to to incentivize him to leave
his computer on to collect fee you know
essentially it's like oh if I leave my
computer on and my counterparty wants to
know Veit and switch with someone else
it might make a buck and my position
doesn't change so cool
so that is doable I do not look forward
to programming that because that now has
three different computers talking to
each other and they all have to do
messages and the right sequence and
stuff and that's not the most fun part
of programming but yeah so anyway so
that's any of this what are some use
cases I can think of some but
all sorts of other ideas I think it's I
think it can be pretty useful you could
do currency futures so I think one of
the biggest would be dollar futures so
right now in CME I think or cibot or one
of those Chicago kind of places or both
of them you can do Bitcoin futures which
are dollars settled Bitcoin futures
right so you get a bunch of dollars
based on the price of Bitcoin yeah so
like you can say I want you know ten
bitcoins for delivery on next week and
then you don't get the ten bitcoins but
you get however much however many
dollars those ten bitcoins are worth
based on some exchange price that they
agree on you know we're gonna use the
average of these different exchanges and
stuff with DLC you could do sort of the
inverse of that where I have bitcoins I
am drew into a contract where I have
dollars being delivered all right sorry
I've bitcoins you know the dollar value
being delivered so the idea is I have
ten thousand dollars worth of Bitcoin
being delivered to me on Friday so if
the price of Bitcoin goes up I get fewer
of them if I if the price of bitcoins
goes down I get more of them such that
the amount of Bitcoin I receive on
Friday is has a value of ten thousand
dollars and that's a pretty
straightforward discrete log contract to
build right you just need to know the
price of a it actually ends up being a
lot easier to think of Bitcoin as the
main currency and then dollars as the
asset being traded so you sort of want
to know the price of $1 in bitcoins how
many Satoshi is a dollars worth and then
you build your contract from there and
so if the price of a dollar goes up you
get you know more of these things so one
side will say okay I've got $10,000
worth of Bitcoin coming on Friday the
other side basically says I get whatever
whatever's left in this you know
contract and and that other side is
essentially like a more volatile Bitcoin
so the price of Bitcoin goes up great
also you get more of them and if the
price of Bitcoin goes down you're really
screwed because your bitcoins worth less
and you lose most of them but I feel
like people will want to do that like
there will be people who are like cool
double volatile Bitcoin you know where
do I sign up and there's also going to
be people who are like I
I think bitcoin is cool but I want to
anonymously and trustless trust lists
except for the Oracle you know not so
trust fully shorted right I want to say
okay I'm not I sort of don't have a
Bitcoin position anymore
however it's it's not it's not the same
in that you don't know who your
counterparty is it's fully
collateralized at the outset so if the
price of you know if both parties put in
ten you know both parties put in ten
coins twenty bitcoins is all that's ever
coming out of this contract right you
can't say hey I want to do like a margin
call you need to put like 40 more coins
in this contract because the price went
down your counterparty just will say
like no I'm you know so so they're sort
of bounded loss and gain for both
parties at the outset also because you
have no idea who your counterparty is
right you can do this totally
anonymously it's it's I don't want to
say it's trustless because you are
trusting the Oracle tip report the
correct price but your counterparty you
don't trust it all right you have no
idea who they are you assume everything
they're telling you is a lie you know
like they're trying to hack you stuff
like that so I think currency futures
would be a big one where people come in
buy and sell stocks might be a big one
there's a lot of issues there with like
insider trading because if you can now
anonymously trade stock futures oh
that's probably something people might
want to do who shouldn't be doing it but
it's hard to enforce because these
Oracle's have no idea that anyone is
actually making contracts and if you
look on the blockchain you never see the
contracts or you might sort of be like
well is this a lightning Network channel
that closed or is this a discrete log
contract that just executed it just
looks like keys
you can't oh that's an important point
given even if you're the Oracle and you
know what you signed the fact that
you're adding these two points means
that unless you knew the original you
know Alice key you wouldn't be able to
tell oh that's Alice's key plus my key
right cuz you don't know what Alice's
key was it never existed independently
you know or Oh Alice and Bob knew it but
you didn't as the orc
and so no one will be oracles won't know
what you know contracts are being
executed even after the fact you can
however prove that you used you know if
you want to if you're Alice you can say
hey this was my contract I can show you
all the terms and you can prove it by
you know signing a message with the
Alice private key and then also showing
that it you know this is my public key
and I got I added it to the Oracles
thing yeah commodities sports there's
all sorts of fun things you can do with
it it's pretty general conditional
payments based on any number or element
from predetermined set cool so any
questions about this yes you could talk
to the Oracles because they'll probably
be publicly known entities and so you
could say hey Oracle's don't sign
don't sign message it I mean yeah but
the actual counterparty is a and B if
it's like OTC if it's just Alice and Bob
sort of talking to each other hey let's
build this contract we both trust
Bloomberg their prices are correct it's
you can't see that this happened at all
Bloomberg has so some Oracle someone
somewhere has to be saying look I'm
going to sign the price of oil that's it
oh yeah yeah so well so yeah most of
these transactions never happen if Alice
and Bob see that the Oracle sign they
don't have to actually broadcast it but
they do need to they do need the Oracles
public key first to build the contract
so if you could try to regulate public
Oracle's but that seems like
yeah the question is the Cayman
Islanders soccer program that Brad
yeah the issue there is the signatures
are sort of usable by anyone you could
say ok well Bloomberg charges money to
provide these signatures in these public
keys but if those get out
everyone knows oh these are Bloomberg
signatures you know these are these this
is the Bloomberg data we can now execute
trades using this data and we do have so
we are limited this eliminates the trust
between counterparties but doesn't
eliminate the Oracle trust but the thing
is the Oracle trust is sort of the easy
problem right there's not too much okay
too many cases of you know if you have
some OTC contracts and you say oh we're
using the price according to Bloomberg
or the price according to The Wall
Street Journal or whatever generally
that works so yeah so what you can do is
I think the place that people will try
to regulate is the matchmaking area
where if it's OTC and Alice just calls
up Bob and you know alice is in the
Cayman Islands and Bob's in British
Virgin Islands or whatever or those the
same thing I don't know they say hey I
want a short oil
I want to go long oil okay and we just
build our contracts between our two
computers and Bloomberg has no idea
we're doing this no one else in the
world has any idea we're doing this and
we have this smart contract but in most
cases people will not know who they're
wanting to trade with right they want
some kind of exchange where we can meet
and say hey I want to I want to short
VidCon you know I want dollars and
someone says oh cool I want double
volatile Bitcoin let's let's meet and
let's make this a contract those
exchanges will probably be more
regulated I guess you could sort of say
hey we need to you to qky see all your
exchange participants but even then like
if you wanted so similar to all coins
stuff now you could say I'm Oprah
operating an exchange out of wherever
and you can't operate an Oracle out of
wherever really because people won't
trust it but you could say I'm operating
an exchange out of Hong Kong
we don't care why see anyone maybe we'll
get shut down in a year but anyway we
you know you you can use the Bloomberg
data feed and enter into these contracts
so yeah it makes enforcement hard
makes me into the whole here from public
policy side is keeping verticals mark
semi regulated and times 400 years
that's what they seem so use for us too
much figure that out so whatever we go
currency interest rates so there was it
the spot market itself was being
manipulated or the spot market says the
price is $50 the Oracle says it's 80
cognition because you're long or shorter
position but you just sort of sue people
and say hey look this Oracle was wrong
like obviously the spot price was this
it's not as hard saying what is this
spot price right
besides simply holes the holes here is
not so much on the oracles which it
could need to closely somebody could
just become an aggregator or
the verticals because the CMA tips for
prices but somebody's in the Cayman
Islands who say we're into state descent
or prices right there would be in crypto
it's all through the banking system and
that's why you're seeing a lot of
exchanges having a hard time getting
basically deposit accounts and banks
yeah because the banking regulators
around the globe were trying to regulate
the one Repsol brass that's harder for
their daily exchange yeah perfect let's
start a computer you've got it you don't
have to ask the air
Oracle's somebody who's single-stock
futures are at the end in this country
so yeah well options aren't right so oh
I didn't say you want to make options
contracts with this you just don't give
the data to one side it's basically the
same construction but like now Alice has
the option to broadcast the transaction
and Bob doesn't but so you could make
options with this or features I mean I
try to server farms
this is a great technology or anything
that is on a useful person very post I
think it has both these cases one of the
big ones will be sort of similar to
Bitcoin where it's like hey I can do
these things that maybe I'm not you know
people don't want me to do and in some
cases they don't want me to do is just
like scale in terms of like okay I'm
some guy in like Thailand and I want to
go along Apple and probably you can
legally do that but if you've got like a
couple hundred bucks and you're in some
random country and you want to you know
go long hour but you know some US equity
that's not really feasible right maybe
you can open accounts maybe you can try
to open a foreign account like it's
there's a lot of friction and so with
this kind of thing it's like hey we've
got you know Bitcoin I trust this price
Oracle okay I'll do it with like you
know a couple hundred bucks worth of
Bitcoin that said there's also cases
where it's like okay I work yet Foxconn
in Shenzhen and I think the Apple iPhone
11 is not going to be any good so I'm
gonna short Apple using this kind of
technology so there will be good and bad
things you could also it could also be
useful in cases between actual regular
legal Wall Street II kind of people
maybe not where then it's good where
you've got like not a lot of trust
between your current parties but you do
trust some kind of Oracle feed and the
other thing is like I have talked to the
sort of Wall Street people and they
don't really like it because they're
like wait there's no leverage right you
have to put all the money you're gonna
get in at the beginning and and they
always want to have it like super
leveraged you can you can crank up the
slope so you can say okay well we both
put 10 bitcoins in but a small
difference in price right so like a 5%
movement in price will like make all the
money go to one side of the other so we
hit the knock in and knock out really
soon so you can do that which is kind of
like leverage but fundamentally it's you
know the only the bitcoins that go into
the contract come out yeah I don't know
how this will be regulated I'm working
there's a company
in Japan who's interested in building
this technology there's like it's a
brokerage that's making this stuff I'm
working on it with some other people
we'll see I don't know how it will be
right maybe people won't like it it's
yeah so I think it'll be gone yeah oh I
think this will be cool I think I think
people would use it I just you know it's
a lot of work to program and I don't
have enough time but uh but I there's
other people starting to get I don't
know it's weird it's sort of like
lightning was like three years ago and
some people were like oh cool and then
eventually people are like oh this is a
really big deal and let's all work on it
and I it might be the same with this
we're like no one really cares and then
eventually people will be like oh hey we
should build this and like use it and
start companies and things like that so
hopefully people get into it I think
it's a pretty nice construction for
these kinds of things it competes
there's things like auger which is I
don't think it's the best idea it had
like the auger the idea is the Oracle is
sort of everyone and like everyone votes
on what these outcomes for different
things were but yeah I don't know I
don't know how far along they are in
terms of their software but that was
also like two or three years ago and
this this could be applied more broadly
like where anytime you have a fear IAM
type smart contracts or something where
you want some external oracle who then
can like sign things and then you you
can use it in a way where the Oracles
signature doesn't show up after the fact
so anyway any questions sounds good